[Music]
okay guys here with Nick Jonas just
designed an awesome line of shoes here
at Nordstrom thank you tell me a little
bit about them my favorite part is
actually the name of the line
14:10 yes a 14-10 came from basically my
initials and J so and being a fourteenth
letter in the alphabet attending J was
planning on coming in here and yelling
at you no offense but because I was like
oh my gosh there's a line of men's shoes
and I want them but they're actually
using those unisex well that's the thing
is not to throw a pun in here but I
might it's for people from all walks of
life and you know it's about bringing
something into anyone from any walk of
life can wear and feel comfortable in
and confident well wouldn't you think
back in your fashion history what is
your biggest fashion regret oh we're
pretty fashionable guys there's quite a
few and I mean everything goes out of
style you know so I think there's over
camo Inge which has been a thing of late
all my friends out there be cautious of
over camo Inge listen part of being a
fashionable person is taking risks and
sometimes those risks go terribly wrong
but don't be afraid to take risks before
we go one final question I do want to
ask you about your single with Nicki
Minaj on the fifty shades darker
soundtrack
[Music]
I know for a fact that is used in sexy I
haven't seen this scene yet but I've
heard from many people that it is a an
explosive scene hmm
choice of words I'm excited to see it
myself I love the song and I love Nikki
she's amazing she killed her verse it's
incredible tonight with the Samsung I
[Music]
might be biased well thanks for the best
and you know I just tried to bring some
soul to it and have fun with a song that
I hope a lot of people have sex too